All right, let's welcome to "The
Next Level"
stage our "Hart of the City"
alum, Mr. Marvin Hunter.
What's up, with you, man?
Chilling, man, chilling.
Pleasure to be here, brother.
Good to see you again.
Yeah, man.
Good to be here.
Let's go back to
when you were 19.
OK.
I want you to explain
something to me, man.
Mm-hmm.
I've got a picture.
Explain this picture to me, man.
That was a-- that was a
mixed-up guy right there.
That's a mixed-up guy, right?
He was trying to find himself.
This is you.
Yeah, man.
- In the Navy.
- That's me.
That's me.
Look at the hat.
Yeah, man.
Look at the hair.
Full of hope.
You look happy about it too.
- I wasn't happy at all.
- No?
- No, no.
- No happiness at all?
No happiness at all.
Do you feel like, uh-- do you
feel like you honed your comedy
talents in the Navy?
Absolutely, absolutely.
You have to.
We had to find something
to break the monotony,
you know, very serious
stuff we deal with.
You know, the stupid shall be
punished is one of the rules
that I adopted early on.
So stupid shall be
discussed and punished.
Wow.
Did you do comedy
shows on the Navy ship?
I did not.
But around the base, I did.
Once you got out there, once
you started killing the scene,
did your swag change a
little bit on the Navy ship?
- A little bit.
- A little bit?
A little pep in your step?
- A little bit, little bit.
Everybody started
looking at you different?
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Because a little-- during that
time, I was single, you know.
- OK.
- So the little girls.
You know what I'm
saying, the little girls?
You know.
- Little girls, little girls.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They like that?
You know what I mean?
Somebody standing on stage, you
know, a little bit of power.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey, you know, hey.
The grumpy uncle
thing that you
said that you adopted from
your father, do you have that?
Absolutely.
Are you that
guy with your kid?
- Absolutely.
- 100%?
Yeah.
No nonsense, man.
You know, no time
to babify people.
Too much of that going on.
No gray areas.
No gray areas at all?
No, no gray areas.
How old is your kid?
He's 25.
- 20-- what?
- Yeah.
And there's still
no gray areas?
- There's no gray areas.
- Goddamn, man.
You know, hey,
they grow up so slow.
You know what I'm saying?
Literally,
watching you onstage,
it's a breath of fresh
air because you have
such a unique cadence, man.
Thank you.
And I think right
now, it is time for you
to go to the next level, man.
There's no reason for you
to still be sitting here.
Go to the next level, Marvin.